not a great perimeter defender on a guy
like Babin so it's a good smart play
will Martin in there as well but soon to
the corner here's Babbitt back to
Lillard Lillard for the win
it had been a quiet half for Damian
Lillard on this night we thought was
going to be a battle of the rookies but
he comes up with the biggest shot of the
night and they're saying don't go away
we've got to review it but I think let's
take a look at the instant replay and
see it was for sure yeah we can look at
it as a formality but this thing beat
the horn and Damian Lillard has a
game-winning shot to his credit watch
this
[Applause]
thank you
all on the floor
review
[Applause]
expect Willow will be the go-to guy here
Bo Williams is out there as well here
comes G again
he shut him down like he did last year
oh are you kidding me at the horn his
fourth game winner and he's mobbed about
to get for Houston nine tents left a
three wins the series it's Lillard he
got the shot off
[Applause]
and the Blazers win the series for the
first time in 14 years
of course it's being reviewed because it
goes in at triple zero but it's out it's
over and the Portland Trailblazers in
shocking fashion when they didn't hit
one outside shot in the fourth quarter
get the Kid
with the big guts to win the series
Damian Lillard sends Portland to the
second round
and very classy here as you look at
these replays they announced that it
stands and the Blazers have won the
series and both teams with
congratulations being shared after a
series that was so close
Wednesday
hard screen nurkish
[Applause]
[Music]
sweet scoop
Miller
will take it for the lead how about the
wrong control
he knew that ball was on his left-hand
side like having sides on Damian Lillard
you got Brandon Ingram with those long
arms guarding Lillard up top Lillard
picked up by Ingram Lillard
this is for the win
0.7
[Applause]
and the Lakers don't have time
absolutely not
like it had eyes Damian Lillard with the
dagger right over the outstretched hands
of Ingram the little step back
of game three and then answered with 15
in the third quarter in game four so
here's Lillard gets up the first shot
and it is true
Westbrook fires a three misses a three
on Westbrook missing shots again he's
now one of seven from behind the arc
Lilly
Portland has been content to let
Westbrook shoot those jumpers Lillard
for three it's down Damian Lillard a
chance to send the Thunder home
Lillard long range three
eggs
[Applause]
oh my goodness look at that shot
to put them out he went for 50 points
that's point that was
47-48-9 and 50 points on that one that's
amazing oh five years ago
Lillard hit a three against your Rockets
yeah
to win a first round series
Damian Lillard for 50 points
[Music]
good night
Oklahoma City sees it over
wow
that's seven points on Saturday down in
Oklahoma Here Comes Whiteside with this
shot rebound horde out to Lillard three
with a half minutes ago coming up the
American Express halftime report what
three little
oh
did he knock that down from great pick
into Whiteside tried to push it down low
little and back outside Lillard with a
three
the comparisons to Draymond Green
because coach Kerr even told us before
the game draymond's been able to teach
him some tricks defensively when you're
that undersized was a playmaker there
and that has been a change in direction
for him
wow he's on his way to one of those
games
[Applause]
Lillard for three
it's off to Anthony
Simons wide open free to fire Lillard
[Applause]
difference of two and a half seconds
game clock and shot clock Willard
working on perks dancing free a free
guard
and this is when Lillard is his most
dangerous right here down by three
[Applause]
he'll try to tie it
over the record
his own record
it's for jumper
Melo snares it
six minutes left Damian Lillard really
aggressive early on in Damien Lillard
and one defensive matchup and Richardson
wasn't having it
game races to the cup and one for the
basket that usually will open up driving
Lanes Dame does not need it
Richardson really up in the grill of
Damian Lillard here eight seconds Dame
able to force the foul the buckets and
Damian lillers not dropped Blazers
trying to extend the lead here Dame
wants another three it's okay to be
greedy if you're feeding the needy
Damien Lillard 49 points
133 left Dame working Damien Lillard
give me 51.
old catch in the bounce pass get fouled
knocked down threes
seven footer Lillard lunging porzingis
Lillard fires it doesn't take much time
for Damian LifePoint lead for the
Blazers who interaction at 33 and 39
Lillard hanging three Damien Lillard got
it off the glass
wow
Damien Lillard too much there took it in
got the easy one over the top 22 for
Luka doncic the blow-by and the
corkscrew for Damien Lillard he's got 53
points
Lillard his career high is 61. he's got
55.
Lillard for three bottom Damien Lillard
cannot be stopped five to shoot a minute
and a half to play that's a bomb
oh my God
ridiculous huge win for the bubble
Blazers behind Damian Lillard 61 points
and Portland he has been treated daily
and I text him asking him if there was
any concern moving forward he said I'm
not worried now I can worry about in off
season Collins up top
Johnson is following nurkic's back out
there here's Dane four assists already
tough three
goodbye Tyler Johnson make it a two
stepped on the line
pretty shot Lillard 30 Footers and wow a
big bomb outside by Damien Lillard
Brooklyn has got nine more points above
the arc
Second Chance points favoring Portland
shot my goodness what a beauty right
there by Lillard for the first time for
Brooklyn
that's without scored Portland image
quarter 35-19 and a minute to go
look at Tim Lillard
he was six of nine oh my God
oh my goodness that was from the NBA
logo oh my
God you've got to be kidding me people
well here comes Damian Lillard 33.
[Music]
this is Papa shot people Chicago with
their highest scoring quarter of the
game here in the fourth quarter so far
damn gets it with white checking Dame
deep look from outside there's the three
and now you deny everything
Levine gets tied up and it's going to be
a jump boss damn with 41 Gary Tran Jr to
jump against a two-time Slam Dunk
champion
Blazers get the tip five seconds left
Covington trying to get it to Dame he
puts it on the floor step back three
from Dame
oh paint it Damien Lillard
game winner in Chicago back to back
threes to break the heart of the Bulls
wow
[Music]
oh scramble
balls loose for a second
game creating space picking on marking
and yet again
again that is an example of how you want
to make it tough for the yokics to
finish in my goodness gracious how about
the rage on that triple three and a half
to play
taking the lead
[Applause]
[Music]
on a triple deadly on the line 9.8
in a three-point game
[Applause]
oh my goodness Damien Lillard the late
game assassin
[Applause]
she's deep three squared on a mate where
he has done everything right
it's the door open Lillard she is a
killer
oh wow it just does not get any better
here he comes
[Applause]
comes it fires
oh my goodness
let's slow this guy down Lillard
[Music]
without their two best shot creators
from the perimeter
[Applause]
Smith yeah he's looking at this
situation now how Nasir little was
looking at the Sacramento Kings game
okay so what the best shot creators on
our roster is out I'm gonna get
something done very accessible all the
time the fans had a great time taking
pictures with various individuals here's
Dame out way outside Grant with it out
on topped a little over it comes to Dane
elevates for three that's a deep one and
he reeled it in oh man
recovered by a little
give game to Christopher and Christopher
on his heels as Dave sees that and goes
to work he's listening to 226 he's every
bit of that
name off the screen leads into a triple
got it see like that that's what I'm
talking about if they keep giving him
those kind of gaps then yes I see 50.
now he's got to finish the job though
reddish for Watford Bullard sets his
feet leans back a three got it Damien
Leonard seven threes on the nine and ten
attempts he has 36.
[Applause]
on the attack missed that one
right at The Rim radish the other way
Dave a deep one buried it Damien Leonard
from long range way out in the deep
water
and pops out comes off the screen
shooting for
three-point range and had nine of his 50
points in the third
off the screen for three Damian Lillard
knocks down a triple Lillard with his
10th three-pointer of the ninth keeps it
to the side rapidly between the
wickets drives inside outside the grant
fakes Hanks finds Dave step back three
powering it up and in with Milling his
arms Blazers by 10 a burst into the lane
[Applause]
comes off the screen
tape with him sets his feet leans back
for three Damien Leonard a career high
the three-pointer for Lillard is 12th of
the ninth
64 points for Damian Lillard in 35
minutes and the crowd is on their feet
[Music]
a little trying to get open does a three
in his sights he's got it Damian Lillard
catch shoot knocked it down gives it
back to Grant Dave will Sprint out on
the sideline to get the Rock
High dribble into the lane running
right-hander up and in Damian Lillard
with that Runner
71 points a career high
22-37 13-21 from three
[Applause]